there was anger on the streets of
Pittsburgh last night after a jury
acquitted a white former police officer
who shot and killed an unarmed black
teen as he fled a traffic stop
hundreds of protesters voiced their
outrage about the verdict and struggled
to make sense of the controversial
decision it is our duty to fight for
freedom
[Music]
[Applause]
a large crowd of protesters gathered
outside of the Allegheny County
Courthouse after a Pittsburgh jury found
former police officer Michael Ross felt
not guilty in the shooting of 17 year
old Antoine Rose last June Rose was
fleeing a traffic stop when Ross Feld
shot him three times in quick succession
he was riding in an unlicensed taxi that
had been involved in a drive-by shooting
minutes earlier hundreds of protestors
lined the streets of Pittsburgh for
several days after video of the shooting
surfaced on social media Roz Feld was
sworn in just two hours before the
deadly encounter he was placed on
administrative leave before he was
eventually charged with criminal
homicide Rossville testified that he
shot when he saw one of the suspects
raise what he thought was a gun his
defense argued that he was within his
rights to shoot on the grounds that he
felt he and the community were in danger
when they get out of the car and run I
think the law is he can shoot oh I don't
think law that is the law attorneys for
the rose family said they knew they were
a long way from a conviction he was
unarmed and he did not pose a threat to
the officer to the community and the
verdict today says that that is okay
that that is acceptable behavior from a
police officer now Rose's family will
continue to pursue the federal civil
rights lawsuit they filed last August
against Ross Field and East Pittsburgh
Rose's mother said that she will
continue to speak up despite the outcome
of the trial